alors analysons maintenant plus en
profondeur ce rapport très attendu avec
notre collègue étienne leblanc
journaliste spécialisé en environnement
bonsoir etienne bonsoir alors il s'agit
quoi du sixième rapport du giec depuis
1990 vous avez couvert la publication
d'une bonne partie d'entre eux en quoi
le premier volet de ce rapport si publié
aujourd'hui se distingue des autres bon
ça fait 30 ans qu'on a publié le premier
rapport en 1990 et l'état de la science
n'était pas la même le haut on voit
vraiment dans ce sixième rapport que la
science et affiner les données qu'on
retrouve dans ce rapport sont de bien
meilleure qualité que même le dernier
rapport en 2014 où les précédents 2007
2003 95 1990 et donc et cela pour
plusieurs raisons parce que bon il ya
lieu de meilleure façon de récolter les
données ya plus de citations de on peut
récolter des données mais aussi les
satellites maintenant qu'il nous a aidé
à récolter les données et la science
climatique c'est une des sciences les
plus étudiés dans le monde évidemment au
cours des huit dernières années 10
dernières années est bien partout dans
le monde maintenant on étudie de plus en
plus les effets des changements
climatiques et donc c'est pour ça que
puisque ce rapport c'est d'une grande
synthèse de l'état de la science sur la
planète étant donné qu'il y a plus de
science étant donné qu'il y a de la
meilleure science ce rapport à des
données de meilleure qualité notamment
et ça c'est vraiment nouveau dans ce
rapport la précision des prévisions
régionales dont parle sur sur les
différents continents on arrive à
vraiment allez zou mais si on veut
beaucoup de beaucoup plus précisément
lisent les effets et les conséquences
des changements climatiques donc c est
une grande avancée la qualité de la
science dans ce rapport voilà un
portrait qui se précise des scénarios
aussi qui se précise maintenant etienne
quelles sont les options qui s'offrent
aux dirigeants politiques à qui
s'adresse directement les experts du
giec après tout bon les options seront
difficiles c'est à dire qu'il va falloir
mener une action drastique si on veut
éviter
la catastrophe si on veut donc si on
veut contenir le monde à un
réchauffement de 1 5 degré celsius qui
est prescrit par les scientifiques ce
qui est dans l'accord de paris et bien
dès maintenant les gouvernements vont
devoir réduire les émissions de 3 % par
année et ce à tous les ans dans les
proches dans la prochaine décennie c'est
pas rien par parce que par exemple si on
veut comparer pendant la pandémie ou le
monde s'est arrêté les gens ou arrêtez
d'aller au travail on arrêtait de se
déplacer chez terra l'économie s'est
fermé les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre ont été réduits de 7 % donc on
voit que de réduire de 3% par année sur
l'ensemble de la planète c'est un
immense défi et c'est pour ça qu'il va
falloir modifier complètement des
structures de l'économie et à la lumière
des plans de relance économique qu'on
voit aujourd'hui c'est pas certain qu'on
va aller dans cette voie tout cas pas
tout de suite peut-être que ce rapport
sera un électrochoc pour les
gouvernements pour les gouvernements in
ou non tout ça vous moi les gens qui
nous écoutent la grande difficulté pour
ce type de rapport et me semble si aussi
de pousser les citoyens à agir est ce
que les experts du giec etienne ci
prenne différemment cette fois-ci
c'est disons que le ton et rope plus
vindicatif ils sont très très préoccupé
les les scientifiques du giec par le
temps qu'ils ont dans ce rapport ils ne
veulent pas être trop alarmiste pour
décourager les gens mais c'est vrai que
dans ce rapport c'est le ton le plus
alarmiste de tous les rapports du giec
maintenant les citoyens c'est vrai
qu'ils peuvent faire leur part mais il
faut aussi que les gouvernements
investissent dans le transport en commun
dans les énergies renouvelables dans
l'achat de voitures propres et chez
terrain pour pouvoir aussi faire leur
part donc on a bien entendu on est dans
un état une étape où les citoyens
peuvent agir mais à une étape tellement
grave que c'est aussi au gouvernement
d'agir et je crois que ce rapport
interpelle dans le fond lead ces deux
parties les citoyens et les
gouvernements mais le message est le
même une situation est urgent et en
quelques mois etienne qu'il est la suite
des choses là que doit-on à quoi doit-on
s'attendre des deux autres volets qui
vont compléter ce rapport au cours
l'année prochaine je serai que les deux
autres volets vont nous interpeller
davantage parce que le deuxième rapport
et sur les impacts les effets des
changements climatiques et la ddt
adaptation qu'on doit faire pour pouvoir
continuer à vivre de façon plus agréable
est le 3e rapport ce sont nos fonds les
solutions pour réduire les changements
climatiques donc des volets qui vont
davantage nous interpeller dans notre
vie quotidienne pour éviter le naufrage
climatique étant redoutée merci beaucoup
étaient des blancs merci au revoir